hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome benda net this is a game
where you play or at least from what
I've seen you play as a zombie going
through a deadly obstacle course and you
try to get to the end with at least one
limb intact and hopefully that's a hello
his been he lives in a crappy world I
can see that it's terrible
he's got the smile face t-shirt one day
been found
edy the first undead okay they became
friends that doesn't seem very friendly
that seems dangerous
Hans show master heard of them he took
them apart oh no to use them oh now for
the greatest game show ever created oh
well this took a leap of logic that I
wasn't anticipating but okay oh god what
am I looking at here huh it's undulating
why is it undulating oh oh I thought
that was something else
nevermind haha I'm up I'm at it baby
whoa I run silly I saw previews for this
game a while ago nope that ain't nothing
and slow down I don't want to slow down
oh maybe if I need patience and
determination which is probably not
something that I actually need haha I'm
so sassy wait what did I just get did I
eat dog food oh no I was I just supposed
to do that for the entertainment and
others is everyone just watching at me
that's pretty much what they do here
watch at me one second
so I needed to floof my hair for power
it happens regularly I need to make it
look as bad as possible a system an
objective here okay II to reattach how
do i D attach huh oh jeez oh God
why I will choose why can I do that
that doesn't why wha Oh God no what is
that a thing ha ha ha body regained good
ok
oh I'm sorry mr. button your life was so
sad and depressing oh god it's so weird
is so weird I love it
hello companion cube happines oh hi are
you beep you okay there you alright but
what are you okay I almost wanted to say
who I'm gonna change it to what so it
became who are you Oh No
Hey oh boy I got a golden Skellington
it's the duteous of the skeletons I'm
doing now press ENTER to respawn a
checkpoint anywhere anytime yeah okay
cool
welcome to I don't know what to do ah oh
oh
ha okay it seems cool I mean it's it's
just gonna be kind of like a gauntlet
style running down and dying was there
more candy meat for me to get I didn't
know there was anything I wasn't looking
I was distracted by the pretty colors
all right fine let's try this
oops no I said let's try this please
thank you yes start no less backstage
it's not what I wanted
ah crap damn it uh main menu
Akira this one's the white one okay
that is a lovely looking [ __ ] chicken
[ __ ] is another term for ticket again
you didn't okay there we go
alright the greatest game show in the
world I'm sure I get paid for this right
whatever death and dismemberment that I
may feel for eternal eternity will
surely be repaid in lovely alive Oh God
yeah not gonna get me laughs oh God no
no I meant a duck oh hi who the hell are
you are you the show master can I tell
you how much I hate you already ah [ __ ]
I forgot to jump I am so bad at this
okay time for the bad to be over now is
the time for goodliness yeah I was
supposed to jump ow oh my eyeball God or
did I go seasons it's okay I can make it
Oh nope
the head is bloated you think that they
just have more zombies instead of just
using the same zombie over and over
seems less than efficient AHA okay now
we got this huh okay I got this I got a
baby oh thank god oh I can still make it
huh oh yeah okay I can still make it
Hey
haha it's so close damn it
alright enough of the suck watch this
with skill uh yeah you you guys at home
need to watch with skill just as I need
to play with skill one of those is much
easier than the other uh-huh okay miss
main dickbag circuit road huh
you think this is a problem for me I've
been doing this since I was 11 euro
oh god damn it this is so close and I
went the wrong way because there was
other stuff on the other direction miss
me
Oh douchebag for what set you hate
yourself bow meet you yes okay there we
go
whoo I know he's so handsome even though
he's dead oh very good
huh huh huh what are you doing over
there what the hell are you I'm leaving
you behind you're not gonna watch me
anymore
freakin perverts yeah yeah I'm a
stealthy dumb B then y'all gonna get me
yeah ah I'm the speedy Asami there was
I'm probably running out of space
because it seems like it's going much
lower than it was before
ah miss me you need your slice off a
piece of this no way no how
ah miss me again what a dick you suck I
win I'm the greatest in everyone and
something I should stop bragging before
I die
my accent is doing relatively okay I
mean I imagine that in most most most
people to play this game when they go
out it the first time prolly are able to
go through these baby levels with
absolutely no trouble and for some
reason I'm having the worst time Wow ha
ha ah skill baby oh that ain't skill
sorry ok what was that I was saying
about skill oh yeah how great I am [ __ ]
god damn it alright hang on we're gonna
get this
ah [ __ ] woo ha and whoop yes yes yes I
am handsome yes I am talented yes I'm
also a zombie they ignore that fact talk
more about how great I am
hee hee ha ha huh ha ha ha god dammit
this is this is actually surprisingly
difficult here I mean I originally
thought that it was gonna be perfectly I
are fine by everything gonna be ok huh
just in case that was a pre-emptive jump
just in case you never know huh oh god
damn it I'm okay hey are they gonna give
me a leg back when I get over here man
buddy Ben Oh Ben I hope they're feeding
you you're surrounded by a whole lot of
Yeahs oh no back into the bend hole oh
poor Ben somehow we're friends oh how
did I miss one I don't know it's obvious
how I missed one terrible the game but
this is fun I might do another level
come on let me get it go here we go
yeah I mean what's the deal with the
board chickens
am I just stomping them to run over them
because it's actually run throw retry
I'm gonna get this on one try I'm gonna
go balls out if you know what I mean
norther it's obviously a pawn because
being chased by giant balls ah ha ha
loser hurt I'm too good for you oh I
thought you could hide that one move
that was confusing buddy Oh God okay oh
oh it's getting into there with all of
your body parts so if you even get
sliced off a little bit you won't get a
golden thing golden skeleton duty dude
unless you get there and fall your body
parts so it's like doing it perfectly
okay well if I've known that I wouldn't
have gone halfway I would have done it
balls out
I got stop talking about my balls being
now alright we're good we're gonna come
at me [ __ ] whoa you can't get none of
this ha ha I'm the best that ever was
even though I'm is a comic oh yeah I
remember ah I don't know why that was
necessary
can I have my body back please is there
gonna be a bridge I'm not gonna be able
to get a golden thing in yeah but get
over it you stupid come on you're just a
dumb ol head there we go
I'm frickin fricker
okay I got a golden duty Kang get my
whole body back thank you oh [ __ ]
well that's off to a terrible start this
test once more run ed I mean who would
watch this amazes its cruelty I think
this like that the end of Shaun of the
Dead when all the zombies were on the
game show and they just had him chasing
pieces of meat and there was one person
that was still married to their zombie
husband you know that's sad and
depressing I mean I mean romantic and
lovefool it's get up in a way that's
kind of like the whole idea of Twilight
technically vampires are what lords
lords of the undead they're technically
Undead right that's the idea isn't it
and so that whole deal Marion and having
sex with a vampire should I'm still
alive a vampire now too much different
than zombie right except for something
probably horrifying goobers
come on how are you not able to do that
what is this buggy ass game [ __ ]
going on it there we go thank you for
cooperating only steamroll these cons
with just my head pan-pan Hey thank you
I don't even know if there's a point to
that it's probably horrible I do meet
bad
mic mic my Sambi morality is going way
low it's like a Bioware games of zombies
all right I know I'm great shut up
whatever oh yeah I know I know I'm
amazing
I hit it look at me I'm the best oh yeah
I know talk more about how great I am
yay damn this is a long stage ah okay oh
haha know who everyone at home is very
entertained by an amazing moves miss me
um Oh Klaus close whoa
and woo ah ah damn it
sir shortcut I figure ha ha ha I'm gonna
do that again
yeah this Prost well [ __ ] yes bro strats
right here come on come at me bro boy
here we go
yes
these bees yes oh yes ah come on I can
do this you ain't gonna bass me not me
baby whoa yep
I know yep I know yeah I know yeah I
know I know it
trust me I know it I know how great I am
trust me I know
and boy oh god there's more to this
level this game must be check kantak
there's like 16 different levels if it's
all about this the content ah think you
hide that from me answers new
I know goodbye [ __ ] sorry that one I
get to leave behind so there be two sets
of mortars dead friend what is this Oh
God uh hey man I almost had you
and I almost destroyed you is so fun
okay so that's Ben and Ed I might play
more of this on my own because this is
getting really interesting and that
clown level does not look very fun so
let me know what you think of this game
down the comments below and please write
some more suggestions for cool games
that I could play in the future thanks
again everybody and as always I will see
you in the next video